this is a production of cornell
university
bernard will lead us off and peter will
take over about halfway through so
without any further ado
thank you very much both for for joining
us today and bernard the floor is yours
yeah thanks a lot andy and also thanks
for the invitation
uh you remember we had planned this i
think earlier this year when we said
let's
still meet in you know face to face in
the u.s by that time you know we'll know
that the covet situation will have been
resolved do you remember that discussion
it would actually have been nice to come
physically to cornell i used to have a
bit of cooperation with cornell some
years ago but it's been
some time now that i've been there let's
let's maybe book this
this next year again or sometime and
thanks also for
for allowing us to talk about the new
initiative
i've developed the slides with my
colleague i'm going
to talk a little bit about the broad
picture of what we call
excellence in agronomy and then peter
will
give a little bit more zooming in he
will zoom in on an initiative that has
basically probably created some of the
arguments why we needed excellence in
agronomy initiative
so the rationale why why why why
agronomy
why you know agronomy is not a new term
it's not a new research area so why do
we need
an initiative across the cgi on that
there's a number of arguments we usually
present
we know there's been quite a bit of
success with crop improvement if you
read publications about the cgr and
impact it's usually around that
but we also know that the expression of
what is called genetic gain
at scale is not always there there is
some recent work from uh
symmets who looked at mace modern they
call it modern variety adoption against
national granules for a lot of countries
in africa
you see very nicely the picture is quite
scattered although in a lot of countries
there is quite a bit of an uptake of
modern maze varieties of course you also
see countries like ethiopia where
there's
actually substantial increases in yield
and we know why that is we know why that
is we know that variety alone is not
sufficient we know that you need your
nutrient inputs
the other side of the coin also shows
this is for instance
fao data on the left side here showing
fertilizer use over time for mozambique
malawi and zambia you see a clear
increase in malawi and zambia these are
majors for the same period and you can
correlate
those data and you clearly see that
there is a noise relationship
of course not all that fertilizer is
applied to that maze
that's that's for sure but there is
definitely a large proportion of it is
in southern africa which is which is
always based
basically so i think we know that but
it's good also to see it confirmed in
data
the second argument and i will not dwell
on this one the science advancement
there's been a lot of development in
tools
methods geospatial statistics big data
analytics
that actually allows us to implement
agronomy to scale
rnd while still being locally relevant
and i'm not going to dwell on this peter
will
dig a lot deeper into this bullet later
on
the third bullet why we feel there is a
large demand for agronomy
at scale with a lot of public and
private partner sectors
which is new by new i mean it's not new
as such but 20 years ago this was not
the case
so while 20 years ago you could have
done excellent signs that demand and
interest was not there today it isn't i
think we know
the cta reports from last year
[Music]
conducted by dalbert which shows the
sort of
deforest company starters present in
africa
with kenya here on the left having at
least 150
uh initiatives we also see on the map
here that although the
the number of initiatives in
in blue is pretty similar between east
and west africa the users in east africa
the orange circle is much
larger than in west africa although
probably today those circuits have
changed already
so of all those companies the insurance
companies agronomy advisory they are
interested in agronomy at scale
solutions and the very last point the
cgr reform process i think andy alluded
to
this there is a reform process ongoing
and it gives us an opportunity
to organize agronomy since
2005 there's not been a unifying force
in the agronomy space in the cgir
um this is these are the centers here
i'm not sure how familiar everyone is
with the centers but we are working with
10
centers which are highlighted here and
we
currently still have about 130
agronomists
involved in quite a lot of initiatives
and and spending about 10 to 15
of the budget so it's still impressive
when we did this study we were a little
bit surprised but it's
mainly through time-bound projects which
come and go which
don't create a lot of incentives to
cross-learn to
share experiences so we want to change
that
now what is the purpose and the scope i
mean this is this is a lot of
um you know big words and difficult
words so i'm not going to read this
but basically what we want to do is
we want to deliver agronomy gain for a
lot of people
because we know that agronomy gain will
have a positive impact on livelihoods
income soil health climate resilience
and we want to do this by setting up
agronomy at scale solutions
these two words in blue i will dwell on
a little bit
what is agronomy at scale and we've had
that question a few times
now what we really want to do is we want
to resolve that conundrum that that
contradiction
that agronomy has been plagued with on
the one hand agronomy is
locally relevant it's place based it
it's it's an adaptive process
but at the same time we need to work
with millions of people on millions of
hectares so how do you resolve this
20 years ago it was not resolvable the
only way you can resolve this 20 years
ago
is you go to a new village and you start
all over again
today we can resolve that conundrum so
what we want to do in agronomy and
scale is we want to assist people
farmers decision makers to take the
right
decisions on those soil and crop
management practices
that are taking place once a season i
would say for annual crops
we want to scrub and soil management
decisions to be influenced
informed by spatial and temporal
variability
we want that advisory to be targeted to
end users needs and to account for yield
profitability sustainability
peter will explain what this means in
practice
the second thing i've mentioned is
agronomic gain
we are currently developing a conceptual
framework around agronomic game
in line with what is called genetic gain
so we are
working around four key performance
indicators increased
use and profitability improved resources
efficiencies
could be nutrients labor increased yield
stability and improved soil health
and of course we know that those kpis
will
vary in importance or relative
importance for for the various regions
of the of the global south
how are we going to deliver that
agronomy at scale and
develop solutions and deliver them with
partners
so we had a co-creation process with all
those centers and he
assisted us with this and a number of
other
external partners and we ended up with
the structure around
four what we call modules this this
sounds a bit
you know a little bit theoretical and so
but i still want to explain this because
it shows
a little bit the different ways in which
we want to do agronomy
so on the left side we have the organize
module which is really hosting the
functions related to
internal organizations partnerships this
is also where we do
the prioritization and demand mapping i
think these are two
key words for the ones the new
excellence in agronomy initiative
prioritization that means having an
objective verifiable framework to decide
where and what you're going to do and
demand mapping
which means we are going to absolutely
respond to
demand by real people working with real
farmers and in real
regions so that will happen here
based on that demand mapping and
prioritization process there will be a
number of projects
one two to n which will start and stop
and which will deliver solutions
at scale depending on the demand that
was formulated now
this projects will be counting
on and using tools and data and
analytics in the transform module which
is this
vertical box here and where we feel
there is not enough
data or analytics available to
immediately use
in the delivery of those products we're
going to the innovate module which is
where the innovative the new r d will be
done in support of agronomy at scale
and of course this these two central
core boxes are influenced
by new data collected through these this
projects
this slide is interesting also because
it shows the docking points for
partnerships
um if we talk you know to your
colleagues and cornell
we at the cgr we will not claim and we
cannot claim that we host
all the skills and capacity needed to
deliver an agronomy at scale program
so we do have a talking point for
international research and academics
through the innovate module so probably
at one time next year we will start
actually
talking to cornell and see what this
means in practice
we have a docking point for the national
system
scientists to the transform module
because we want those tools to be
accessible used and
[Music]
empowering national systems to use those
tools and data
we have our demand partners here the
country engagement the private sector
all the people who need our agronomy
and we have a docking point for a donor
interest group so this is this is
this slide is is really in one slide
summarizing a lot of the
logic and partnerships that we want to
set up to deliver
on our on our vision
in term just a few more slides to dig a
little bit deeper into those modules
in terms of the organized module as i
said one of the key
innovations that we want to apply in
agronomy is
a very very conscientious process on
prioritization
i've worked in agronomy myself for
i usually say more than 10 years
although it's almost 30 years
and sometimes if you look back you see
that
a lot of projects you go you do your
work your demonstrations but you don't
decide or you've not reflected well on
why you do certain activities
and is the enabling environment
insufficient is the
the potential for scaling really there
so we want we want to
be absolutely objective and explicit
about that so we
are developing a three-stage process
where we start to define
where the agronomy can make a difference
in terms of farming systems countries
and status of our key performance
indicators
within that do the demand mapping and
look at
the conditions for uptake of agronomy at
scale
and then have an exotic assessment
framework on on potential solutions on
our technology packages that we would
like to deploy
in respond to that demands within a
certain geography so there's a lot of
discussion going on
this is work in progress but i wanted to
highlight this as a key
innovation and the way we want to
organize our agronomy research
the transform module peter will talk
much more about that that's as i said
the core
that's where the data and this data
solutions on the left are and where the
analytics and turnkey
models on the right side are just one
example we are going to work
quite a bit with the big data platform
of the one cgr this is
recent work so they've looked at their
guardian database
uh assembled fertilizer response data
from 760 locations
used machine learning procedures on
those data
obtained price data and computed
profitability
in space and based on that
could map the profitability of
fertilizer
within the continent with not only a
profitability on average but also
error bars around that so i think this
this shows the power of big data the
power of what you can do if we are
better organized than assembling our
data
in terms of the tools the turnkey
solutions
peter will talk a lot about our african
cassava agronomy initiative
i've shown this slide quite a few times
so now i can also
explain it but i think peter peter will
do a better job so i will hand the
the explanation of this slide over to
him
in terms of innovate this is think where
we absolutely need to talk to cornell
and other colleagues in the u.s and
elsewhere
here we want to do new r d which is
actually
potentially triggering new demand for
agronomy solution this is just one
example on where we want to engage in
measuring
yield at scale within season to increase
the efficiency of our
agronomy workflows and so on and so on
but there will be a lot of opportunity
other opportunities to
to advance the signs of agronomy
the last module the delivery module we
have actually
phrased around the number of key steps
around the generic workflow
it took quite a bit of time to develop
this workflow but it's also based on a
lot of
learning and probably a lot of earlier
mistake making
so on the left side number one
agree on the core partnerships that's
where we place the demand for agronomy
and number two step number two under
that develops the tool
the minimum viable product what is that
decision to
that we are going to develop in response
to that demand i will not go into detail
with a lot of the other steps but once
you have
that mvp described very well
we need to go and assembling the data
and the tools
go into prototyping and very important
step five
going to the validation process and here
we've learned by experience that the
validation process is not
just a technical process a set of
technical processes
you can test tools look at the
recommendations implement them and look
at yield differences that's what we
would do as agronomists
but we've learned from experience that
the user experience
the way the recommendations are
formulated and made accessible to people
the way they are interpreted
is as important as the technical content
itself
and we've learned by doing that you know
being demanded
with agronomy you have to have almost
equal importance given
to the technical aspects as to the user
experience aspects and then of course
you go into scaling and so on
so in our current work we are currently
operating a two-year incubation phase
we have identified 10 of what we call
use cases that are now under
implementation and which are all based
on actual demand from
a specific demand partner on a specific
agronomic issue in a specific geography
so we have six of them in africa
we have two of them in asia one in egypt
north africa
and one in latin america and each of
them
has a partner an agronomy
needs a cropping system and a geography
in which this will be applied
and of course i will not have time to go
into all this but
maybe to give little bit deeper into one
example the
example of digital green
in ethiopia digital green is an ngo
probably some of you know them
they are planning to reach 25 000
farmers
in wheat production system and they are
interested
in how they can increase retails
and quality of wheat so not just heal
but also the quality of the consistency
the
nutrient content so they want advisory
on uterus surveillance planting data
advisory and nutrient management
that's their demand they do have a
platform in which they provide
information to pharmaceutical
voice and they actually have an online
platform to collect feedback so we've
set up a partnership with digital green
the national systems
ministry of agriculture and then some
course support from usaid and so on
and this this use case which is that
tool
that will be submitted through ivr of
sms
information on this particular topics
will then be
piloted and validated and
ultimately developed in a form ready for
scaling so this is just one example
but we do have 10 of those examples so
this is my last slide from here peter
will take over as i said
my job was to sketch in broad lines
what excellence in agronomy is about
what we try to do
at the same time inviting cornell to
join us
help us with some effort and i've also
tried to
probably show that a lot of the
tools are work in progress or under
development so we will need support to
to develop to finish their development i
will stop sharing and i
assume peter will take over now yeah
very good
thanks thanks andy over to peter
thanks a lot bernard i can see your
screen peter
thanks andy and uh thanks to everyone
for uh for also giving me the chance to
to present some of the work uh um
so like bernard gave already uh quite a
number of hints i'll i'll try and dig a
little bit deeper into
some of the work that's been happening
through the african cassava
agronomy initiative or um or akai and
give some um some meat to the bone of
some of
the concepts that bernard has just
has just spoken about so as a means of
introduction um
i just like to show um a typical african
landscape
uh farming landscape so this is from uh
from north tanzania where you typically
see you know lots of small
holders um dispersed in the landscape
there's slopes there's different crops
there's a lot of banana here
different plots erosion happening you
see some good plot some bad plots
dark green crops and very pale yellow
crops um
so this is a very typical um situation
um and providing advice to that's
relevant to small holders
you know you need to take into account
that sort of heterogeneity that that
you'll find
so whatever you're going to promote is
definitely not going to work
in each and every farm and each and
every plot of every farm
but if you if you zoom out um and if you
look at africa
you know from from high up in the sky
there's also a lot of
variation at that scale um so here you
see
actually east africa you see on top
there you see lake victoria and on the
right you see mount kilimanjaro
so if you if you look at that scale you
know you have to deal with a lot of
different soils
from very acid to to actually high ph
soils
in this area even and and
also that sort of heterogeneity needs to
be needs to be taken into account
actually that's that's
often easier to do because we have
digital soil maps
um this is this is just uh some showing
you
um soil ph values um from from soil
grits i'll talk a bit later
more about that and and this digital
soil information we can we can use that
when we provide economic advice
so like i said if we want to advise
farmers you know
over the past decades we've seen
numerous papers that talk about
you know there is need for local
adaptation um
integrated so fertility management you
know requires
adapting your recommendations depending
on the type of sort of
field you're looking at sometimes you
see soil fertility varying as much
within a single farm as across the
entire continent
so blanket recommendations won't work
there will never be a one-size-fits-all
so that brings me to agronomy at scale
and and what it means
um to be to be locally relevant as the
title set
um but still working you know
at scale to service farmers across
across the landscapes
and the heterogeneity that i've just
shown
so what does that approach mean what we
did in in the project and i'll
just introduce the project in the next
few slides
what we try and do is we we we do field
experiments we're agronomists we like
trials
um and we try and understand um what
sort of interventions work under what
circumstances
then we apply crop models um to predict
what will happen in sort of the next
farmer's field and
gis and geospatial statistics to
extrapolate that
then pour that into some form of
decision support tool that we can put in
the hands of a farmer
and promote and scale that in very
simple terms that's that's what the
project tries to do
so i'll try and show a little bit in
more detail how how that workflow
happened in in the project but first
before that
these are a couple of sort of things
that that you know we
we talked about advances in in the field
of agronomy and some of the tools that
became available and that we're sort of
applying in this project we're talking
about using gis
to assist us with sampling locations but
also extrapolating our results
we're doing field trials with very
effective experimental designs and
using actually efficient data management
systems within those to make sure that
any data we collect we can actually use
within 24
hours after collecting it we do a lot of
stats and
geospatial work we use not just trials
but also surveys
um sometimes um
measuring things in farmer's fields can
actually get you answers
much faster than doing trials
we use a lot of methods that are fast
and accurate but sometimes less precise
sometimes spectral methods in the field
to look at nutrient deficiencies
um also with soil samples when we
analyze those and we have
large numbers of samples rather than
going through these into a wet chem lab
we
try and measure those very quickly using
near-infrared for example
crop modelling i'll talk quite a bit
about that and
and software and decision support tool
development so the
african cassava agronomy initiative this
is its logo
is is one of um it's a number of sister
projects
and that that have worked on this
agronomy at scale
and of course this project is now
specifically on on cassava
so we we try to develop
new technologies tailor these um
to the to the heterogeneity of farmers
and and deliver
recommendations to 000 farmers that was
our
our goal and we set out in 2016 when we
started this project
we operate in nigeria and tanzania and
we work with
with many many farmers many many
partners
talk a bit more about that in a minute
but
like i said the the core thing that we
really wanted to to achieve is really
having evidence-based recommendations
that are as much as possible
tailored to to be as as as locally
relevant as possible
so today some numbers you know we've
we've involved over 20 000 farmers
in field experimentation we've run over
5 000 5000 on-farm
field trials those are research-managed
trials
but conducted on-farm and we've taken
over 50 000
cassava yield measurements in in those
farmers fields
than 90 percent of all the data we've
generated comes from farmers fields so
we've done actually very little
on station work
we work on six use cases um
these are sort of demands that were
formulated within the project by the
primary partners
these partners are people that are on
ground
they are ngos they are fertilizer
companies they are starch processing
factories
who actually formulated what they need
in terms of agronomy advice
um to to service their um their clients
their farmers that they're working with
so we have for example fertilizer
companies who ask for better blends
formulating better blends
ngos who work on inter-cropping
practices of or planting practices
including tillage and wheat control
we have starch factories who want advice
on when to plant and harvest so that
they can get year-round supply of roots
to their factories
and several several partners actually
are interested in fertilizer use to
to increase productivity so now i'll
talk a little bit more about
about the fertilizer work as as an
example
much of the approaches i'll show we've
also applied to the other use cases
um but this one is is a bit special and
and i think a very good example of
how we work so we started off like i
said we're agronomists we like to do
trials and we did we did many of those
and we started with neutrino mission
trials
very simple trials where we applied high
rates of nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium and then looked at what
happened
if we omitted any of those elements
this is just a typical example you see
you get high yields if you apply the
nutrients
you you take those nutrients away the
yield drops substantially
but there's a lot of variation we don't
see the same everywhere
this is just an example plot from our
first season in nigeria
so we see that in some farmer's fields
omitting nitrogen
reduces the yield a lot in other plots
of farmers
it's not so much the cases
in the meantime we've done many many of
those
of those trials we've done about i think
close to a thousand of them
um we have over 5000 close to 5000 plot
yield measurements
so that's that data sort of served us to
to start doing some modeling and we
actually coupled
two um two models
we used lintel and more recently
actually we switched to dsat
together to give us water limited yields
using geospatial weather data
and we use soil data also geospatial
soil data and
fed that to quests um but we
let's say dismantled crafts a bit and
replaced some of the parts by machine
learning to predict
indigenous nutrient supply from the soil
we also combine that with
some some variables that we got from the
farmer himself um
so we use soil grids um this is just the
maybe
this is again ph i think sword grids
actually offers um digital soil
information
on most of the um traditional uh
soil soil parameters
and then what you typically see is these
are this is
more recent data this is um yield with
fertilizer versus
versus a control yield um you see this
sort of typical spread
you have typically with higher yields
more variation but also larger responses
until you reach of course very high
yields and then you don't see yield
decreasing anymore
now what you see is actually that the
current yield is often best the best
single
indicator for the expected response if
you see the yield is low
typically you also expect that the
fertilizer response will be low and we
use that information
to define some yield categories and and
farmers can easily identify with them if
you if you turn that
into pictures for example like this
and you tell them you know this is the
typical cassava plant
you know which one is the most common in
your field and they can actually easily
relate to that and say you know
my field most often our clans look like
this
so that's a way for us to actually
identify what kind of
of um yield category or
or yield class we're dealing with and
that's one of those variables that we
and we added to
to the model to to predict indigenous
nutrient supply
now from all that data we're also able
to to see what kind of
what level variability in a nutrient
response occurs
maybe not unexpected from from the
pictures i showed in the beginning
some of that variation happens at a very
local scale
that's in this case the green part of
this bar
between fields from one field to another
a very
very small scale but also at the
regional level
i'm referring back to that to that map
of east africa where you see
between regions at a much larger scale
also an important
level of variation now if we try and
predict that um using soil information
from soil grits alone
we didn't do too well um there are
squares of
0.3 0.5 at most so we're not able to
really predict
nutrient supply and response
consequently but if we combine that with
that sort of local information
that we got from the farmer including
those yield categories
um we did substantially better and good
enough actually to
to start predicting um and going further
with that so we get our squares of 0.6
to 0.8
which we were very happy with
then the next step of course is we we
also need
the the yield ceiling so we need to know
what water limited yields
as sort of the maximum level
of yield that farmers can attain now for
cassava being
an annual crop an indeterminate crop
actually farmers plant cassava almost
at any point in the year in nigeria
and they will also also harvest it at
any point of the year
sometimes very early after eight nine
months sometimes they leave it in their
field for 15 to 16 months
so this has important implications also
for the kind of yields that farmers can
can get and what kind of responses to
fertilizer
so to to take that into account we used
dsat and we ran
over 460 million gridded runs of that
model
with rainfall data from the past 25
years
so that gave us data like this
for one pixel for example depending on
when farmer's plant and harvest
we could have a prediction of what the
yield would be
and also interestingly some some some
level of confidence or variation due to
rainfall which helps us to to make
predictions on
on risk and uncertainty on fertilizer
response
so then we're not done we'd still then
we have yield predictions we have
fertilizer response predictions or
nutrient response predictions um
but to give advice to farmers we don't
need to tell them how much n p
and k to apply to get a certain yield we
need to tell them
how much fertilizer to apply to get a
certain
net return on that investment so farmer
is not
necessarily interested in getting the
highest yield
but the highest profit so we coupled all
this then to an economic optimizer
which basically converts nutrient
responses
to fertilized responses instead of yield
to be optimized for
net revenue
so that allowed us to build maps like
this one for example
these are two states in nigeria and on
the left it shows
a recommendation for a urea application
and on the right hand side the kind of
yield
improvements that farmers can expect for
a certain yield class this is
so we can provide this to extension
workers and then they can use that to do
cost benefit analysis
for example
when we run this on a smartphone and
i'll talk a bit later about that
you can actually work with merc with the
gps capability of the smartphone to do
this at a much higher resolution
and it looks more like this
so then the last step in that whole
process after we've done all that work
we want to actually
validate that the recommendations we
come up with are
are good are profitable for farmers
so what we did is basically laying out
lots and lots of
very simple trials just two plots a
control
and our recommendation just next to each
other we color coded them
and blue and yellow in this case
and we did many of those we did over
5000 of those
and then we can look at how farmers
actually performed we see that over 75
percent
do realize a yield and a profit
improvement
and only two percent actually had a
negative impact
so with fertilizer you don't expect
really much negative yield
effects but fertilizer costs something
so it's not just
um yield effect but it's also getting
that
money back from your investment in
fertilizer
so that made us very happy and this is
another way of looking at these results
these are
cumulative probability distributions so
the more the curve
to the right and the larger the
proportion of farmers that that had
a positive return on their investment or
positive yield effect in this in this
case
um so we did that during during two
seasons
in in both nigeria and tanzania and we
were
really excited about these results
now we've done all that next question is
then
how do you put that actually to use in
the hands of a farmer
how can a farmer access that information
and and actually do something with that
without without us needing to
to intervene directly now this this is
where akilimu
comes into place and this is the name
that we've given to
to our decision support system um
it's turned out more of a platform now
today
but akilimo is actually two swahili
words and pulled together it's aquili
which means brain literally
or smart and kilima which means
agriculture
so giving that that that whole thing
actually a name has has also
um really helped us to to to sell it
and this is the slide bernard being
referred to so this sort of
embodies what wadaki limo is it's a it's
a digital service to provide
tailored agronomic advice so on the left
box you see all that all that science
we've done
all that data and all those models they
sit on a cloud-based prediction engine
that can run those models with input and
provided through different interfaces
that's the
the middle box there and we built two of
those
interfaces ourselves we've built a
smartphone app
we've also made some simple tools that
people can print that
simplify those recommendations to to a
two-pager that
people can easily print and work with
but in the meantime we work with several
digital app companies who have
integrated that service into their
service and and some of these provide
the recommendations over an interactive
sms system
or through a chat bot or to an ivr
an interactive voice response system
so that farmers can actually directly
interact with our recommendations
these are examples of those two pagers
those printable for
leaflets that basically show in a in an
as visual way as possible
and the critical elements they go hand
in hand with
with worksheets again two pagers
where farmers are basically led through
the basic calculations that need to be
made and we've trained extension workers
to help farmers complete those and
they're available all
in in local languages seven or eight
local languages in the meantime
these are some screenshots from our from
our app that we've built
the app obviously gives a much higher
precision than the paper-based can
um but the limitation there is that many
farmers don't have
smartphones and that these sort of this
this sort of tool
is mostly used by an extension worker
who would interact with farmers
so our reach is is let's say much more
limited
than with printable tools
now coming to the end um some
conclusions that that
you know we've been um coming to
in the last let's say one one year maybe
a bit more
we've um we've been pushing this this
sort of system through
and the the the dissemination strategies
of our partners
and today over 82 000 users are actually
registered and applying our
recommendations
now for farmers to to actually profit
or gain from those recommendations they
they need to be reached first they need
to understand
how to use them they need to effectively
use them
do something with the information in
their farm and then and then realize
their profit
so each of those steps we can we can get
some feedback of
of what is happening in their farms and
we've done quite a bit of survey work um
we've done some
some some um
choice experiments for example we've
done phone interviews and sms surveys
and we're
getting a lot of interesting feedback
and we're seeing for example
that use an uptake is is very much
affected by maybe the traditional
factors age
younger people are often more quick to
do something with this sort of stuff
educated farmers typically more than
illiterate farmers as with traditional
extension systems we often see that men
have more access to these sort of tools
than women
often women don't have a phone and are
relying on their husband for
for getting a phone so it's it's not
necessarily true that digital methods
are as accessible to to women as to men
wealth state is very important whether
they are growing cassava for the market
or for sustenance um the dissemination
methods that are being used in the two
format all these have have an important
impact on on on use of our tools
this is my last slide um very
interesting also this is some very
recent work
is is when we look at behavior and and
perceptions around our tools we've we've
actually confronted farmers with
40 different statements to do with the
user friendliness
the the the trust and
confidence that our recommendations will
improve yield
perceptions around risk and cost and
affordability
market orientation um orient
um attitude towards innovation if you
look at all these things
um what comes out very clearly is that
if you
if you use variable selection methods to
see which sort of perceptions
determine whether a farmer is going to
make use of your recommendations or not
what comes out in the very top is
everything to do with with the user
experience
so if they cannot access the advice
quickly and it's all intuitive to to use
those tools that is going to
determine half halfway already
whether that farmer is going to do
something with that advice or not
so with all the signs we've invested you
could actually argue that
that as much effort would need to be
invested in
in making those tools as user-friendly
as possible because because that
determines
whether all that will have any impact
and then next in line
luckily for us agronomists follows the
perceptions around yield and revenue
some cost and market access and maybe
surprisingly lost in line is is you know
the attitude towards innovation how
often do they actually
interact with extension services or have
they made any investments in their farm
in the past
so like i said aquilimo we're trying to
push it into
turn it into more of a community where
people can contribute and interact
and turn it into a learning platform
making it available to the excellence in
agronomy and transforming it into
something
that can grow and inspire a lot of the
work that will happen through
through actions and agronomy
um i need to acknowledge all the
organizations
that have that have worked and all the
people in these organizations and they
are they are really many
um i can't possibly name all of them you
can see from the logos that
there are really a lot of organizations
but many not mentioned here as well
and with that i'll stop here thank you
for listening i'm
happy to answer a couple of questions
thank you so much peter thank you
bernard um we have a couple
minutes for questions so i'm going to
open the floor
are there are there questions for for
peter bernard
yeah i have a question here louis
speaking
please go ahead away yes so i was
wondering if you have experience with
accessing farmers data such as
[Music]
like the planting date or how much did
they apply
and how much did they actually harvested
is there a way for you to access that
data via maybe smart
phones or such technologies
on on planting and harvest schedules we
have quite a bit of information
[Music]
well in the research process we gathered
that through surveys but now that people
are using our tools
and we actually get that information as
part of the input to the recommendations
so we
we ask farmers when they plant and when
they intend to harvest to be able to
calculate
um a sort of expected yield for that for
that planting and harvesting schedule
getting yield data is is actually a very
tricky thing it's it's
um it's not easy and definitely not for
a crop like cassava which is
which is a root crop where often what
you see above ground
not necessarily says much about what
you'll find below ground
um we've we've experimented with a
couple of methods to
[Music]
to combine quick above ground
measurements with
with minimal uprooting and sampling of
well crop cuts and sampling plants
with modest success i would i would say
but yeah
getting yield data in in smallholder
farms fields
in a in a quick and sufficiently
accurate way
is is i think still quite a challenge
andy thanks
please go ahead david yeah uh when i saw
the tool it looked very nice you gave
them
one statement about what they could
expect to see but you have behind that
a lot of simulations so couldn't you
give them a
an uncertainty estimate on that also to
say well this is what we think you
will get if you do this recommendation
but
uh we this is kind of the range and
would that then allow them
to make a kind of a risk-based decision
for themselves
and that's a good question we we um
we we've tried several ways of actually
visualizing or explaining risk to
to small holders and that's not easy to
do
very often when you when you confront
them with ranges
they tend to forget the lower end and go
for the upper end and get very
optimistic
so what we've actually done is is
asked them how often they they
invest in in technologies and then
assume that farmers who often
invest in technologies are more the um
risk-loving
type of farmer and and then what we do
is we actually set our threshold for
profitability
lower for those farmers than for farmers
who
who never invest and who can't afford
the um
losing money so that's very clever
thanks yeah
there are more questions from the floor
yeah i have a question hi
this is johannes hi bernard good to see
you um
nice to meet you peter and uh thanks for
coming
um even if it's not the traditional way
um i was wondering
you obviously you spent a lot of time
and and it's looks superb
uh your interface to the farmers and and
and
populations in rural communities um
where you employ
really nifty uh tools um
how does that look on the on the
upstream side um
bernard you mentioned uh your your
design
and in reaching out more in a more
organized fashion to the
academic research community um but you
spend a lot of
a lot less time in in in
employing these kind of next generation
tools to
to pull in uh knowledge and expertise
and skills
from upstream as you do downstream is is
there something that you can learn
from the downstream side to to engage
both
in in a more rapid iteration with
innovation but also the longevity of
um building strategic partnership i
think i think there's
both of those and they're not they're
not going hand in hand necessarily i was
wondering about that
what years about your strategic maybe
maybe one
maybe one comment you honest you know
this this whole initiative is new and
i've tried to
what peter has been showing is one
project
that started in 2016 but the bigger
picture i've tried
the boring part of the seminar you know
that's the new initiative that's being
constructed since
maybe one year now so one we recognize
the need for
innovation we recognize the need for
linking with
institutes like cornell but we want that
innovation box
also to be demanded uh to a certain
extent we don't want to do the things we
would love to do we want to do the
things we should do
in response to needs and so on so that
probably will be a little bit
opportunistic because you also need to
explore new avenues and agronomy at
scale and we will do that
but we want to use the fields the sort
of things that peter has been showing i
think he referred to a few
items which were difficult or hard or
not satisfying
i think these are very good entry points
into innovation r d that we want to
invest in to exactly
increase the efficiency of our agronomy
workflows and so on so
absolutely um we are
if all goes well and this and if with
the capital
if all goes well then we'll probably
um start working on a much more defined
initiative probably you know from
quarter two next year
with an end line of quarter four next
year
so there will be an intensive period of
reflecting on the sort of question you
just asked
but many other questions and
i think that would be the good time to
touch base again
johannes yeah
thanks
andy can i ask a question this is janice
janice and then harold please go ahead
james okay terrific um
i'm interested in knowing the role of
soil analysis
underpinning all of this i mean how much
of that is done or do you really rely on
historical yields to predict what's
needed
and i guess my question is really
leading to whether
the soil dock system is involved here
whether that's part of this program
or not thanks
will you try peter i can comment on yeah
go ahead peter go ahead
go ahead yeah it's it's not
though at some point we we have some
some discussions with
um with patrick and we wanted to try out
whether
whether having the soil doc data as as
additional covariates in our prediction
model
um would improve improve our predictions
um like i showed we we currently rely on
the soil grid
data alongside with with local
information that the farmer provides
himself
herself um and
we don't include actual measured soil
data at this point because most farmers
would not have
such data obviously for their for their
farms
um right but it's i think
i think the key point peter is that if
you use all those geospatial
information layers that are available
everything you know even
soil grids anything and you predict what
inherent nutrient capacity would be
you don't get very far but if you add
one measure of local quality
to that you get very well to 0.7.8 with
point seven point eight you can do
business
with point three you cannot and that
local what we've seen or what peter has
shown is that you don't necessarily need
to analyze yourself just a pictorial
appreciation of yield is good enough
okay
you can imagine the cost and time and
effort you know to let people look at
the picture or
take a sample and analyze it i mean it's
a totally different absolutely
great thanks will that stand everywhere
all the time for all groups
i don't know but it's nice to see it for
cassava
very good thank you thanks janice harold
you had a question
yeah um well first of all thanks
gentlemen for outstanding presentation
beautiful slides and uh very informative
um just uh kind of following up on
janice's question
so you're you're looking at you know
some of the basic soil
properties and soil grids and and and
nutrient contents and then you're
also looking at you know a yield
potential and and so to some extent
you're dancing around the concept of
soil health
and um and your approach is is fantastic
and uh so in a way it takes maybe this
is the sort of the general
quality or health of your soil and this
is then what you need to do these are
our recommendations
but i was just wondering you could also
sort of turn it around a little bit
and say you know you can
improve the productivity or the health
of your soil
whichever way you express that if you do
this or that so you can make
your soil more like this other soil
and thereby enhance the productivity of
that soil
and and so i was wondering whether in
your
communications through through this app
you may have an opportunity to to sort
of bring that
concept also into um
into the communications that you have
with the farmers because you know
obviously
you're mostly focused on mineral
fertilizers which is fine that's
you know that's typically the first step
um but i just
was wondering whether you've thought
about taking that
to a different level by by bringing in
concepts around soil health and how you
can
help these farmers sort of achieve
higher yield potentials
by enhancing the quality of their soils
yeah um yeah it's a very good question
and maybe
maybe the impression from my slides is
indeed that we heavily focus on on
fertilizer
though this is just one use case and
um in many of our tools we
we actually emphasize the importance of
for a farmer to to know the productivity
of his field
um we often visualize also that you
could look at a field from being very
poor to very fertile and if it's very
poor
you need to think about improving that
soil by we actually having
no our tools you know promoting the use
of manure or compost or
crop residues and recycling those um
and and also emphasizing these for for
long-term productivity that
you need to maintain your soil you need
to avoid erosion
so all those things they definitely come
along
um with with the advice um
but the incentive for a farmer to to
invest
will always be the short-term profit
that he can realize
from from an investment in in tillage or
fertilizer or a new
a new variety just alongside with that
you you really need to
to provide also the advice of of how to
ensure long-term
productivity i very much agree with that
i'm not sure if i answered your question
though
harold is that uh you have a phone yeah
i
i i don't wanna just
um but you know it's a consideration to
to think because i think you have a very
rich
um set of a very rich data set that i
think you could employ
probably effectively in terms of
of you know maybe helping farmers
understand
you know how soil productivity
um can be enhanced not not only by
applying mineral fertilizers but um
by other you know you know
physical biological sort of uh
approaches
um and in a way you have
you have so much data at hand that um i
think with some creative thinking you
could really enhance that
i think it's just a an opportunity that
i just sort of wanted to point out
and i don't really have really good
answers but i i i think there's
something there that could be pursued
no i think harold the main entry point
towards improved soil held the sphere
the organic resource
pathway um that's that's one of the most
viable you know entry points
and we all know in a lot of those
systems the most limiting
resource is organic matter so how do you
increase the availability of organic
matter if you don't have fallow systems
anymore and i think
you know we've always seen that somehow
passing through chrome residues is a
good way forward
and we know that to produce crop
resistance you need your nutrients and
so on and so on
um of course in fellow systems which do
still exist in large parts of
africa the situation is of course
different and there you have
you have those resources available so
it's it's
it's a mix of you know knowledge and
availability of resources that will
drive what what are your entry points
towards better yields
yeah anyway just adding on
this will be a rich subject for when you
guys uh this is something we should
discuss when we are live
in cornell you know and you know and
absolutely september september next year
yes
i'll be vaccinated okay
look we are we are way over now you guys
have been very generous with your time
it was a really fantastic
uh joint presentation and i i
really look forward to as we said
inviting you
to be spend time with us in the fall and
some of these
new projects mature and and uh affording
of course
the opportunity for for deeper
discussions but on behalf of everyone
who's attended thank you so much i
really deeply appreciate it that you you
guys made time for this
yeah and we thank you also for making
time for
listening and and let's yeah let's uh
let's
let's keep this discussion warm andy and
colleagues yeah
thank you everyone all right have a nice
rest of the day
yeah all right thanks again bernard
peter
really yeah take care talk to you on
monday morning
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu